un message clair adressé au gouvernement
par les restaurateurs
ces professionnels rassemblés ce
mercredi pour exprimer leur colère
craignent une annonce qui pourrait être
un ultime coup de massue à leurs
activités
les élus à prendre leurs responsabilités
à prendre des décisions fortes
ça s'appelle couvre-feu ça peut
s'appeler confinement territorialisées
alors il faut l'accepter
nous n'avons pas perdu le contrôle nous
sommes dans une situation qui est
préoccupante et qui justifie que nous ne
soyons ni inactif né dans la panique la
crainte qui circulent
évidemment de voir un couvre-feu alors
qui rappelle des heures sombres de
l'histoire de france qu'on associe sa à
la guerre annoncé un couvre feu se
serait un constat d'échec et on a
aujourd'hui un premier ministre qui
était le ministre du déconfinement c'est
le ministre de la déconfiture
notre logique c'est pas de remplir les
ré à notre logique c'est empêcher les
gens de mourir déchirure et pour cela il
faut pas qu'ils aient forme grave et
pour cela il faut lutter avec efficacité
et y compris quand c'est hélas contre
certaines libertés de circulation contre
la diffusion du virus c'est vital pour
les 20h
et après quand il vous plait le
couvre-feu on en parle et on en parle
et puis on va en parler et puis après on
en aura parlé et il n'y a que des
annonces mais exactement la même chose
avec darmanin ça ne va pas durer
de tout le monde sera puni il faut que
ça cesse nous sommes très bien mais
c'est nous on a un gouvernement de la
parole on a un chef de l'état qui parle
tout le temps
en effet ce virus que nous connaissons
maintenant depuis le début de l'année
qui nous frappent depuis huit mois
revient nous sommes dans ce qu'on a
souvent appelé cette deuxième vague et
ça remonte partout en europe
au moment où nous nous parlons une
dernière danse au mépris de tout
distanciation sociale
hier soir à liverpool cette foule de
jeunes protestent contre la fermeture
totale des pubs effective dès
aujourd'hui
donc la décision que nous avons prise
c'est en effet un couvre-feu un
couvre-feu qui va s'appliquer à la
région ile de france vous le dire le
virus circule très activement et à
plusieurs métropoles à huit métropoles
en plus de la région ile de france au
royaume uni comme ailleurs en europe les
annonces tombent en cascade en espagne
dans la province catalane bars et
restaurants ferment pour 15 jours tandis
que madrid la capitale expérimente
depuis vendredi un recond finement
partiel ce couvre-feu il se fera entre
21h et 6h du matin et il commencera à
partir de ce samedi 0 heure il ya une
voiture de police avec trois policiers
qui circulent dans la ville ya plus de
policiers dans la plupart de nos
communes
c'est vrai à toulouse c'est vrai à
marseille ça veut dire que si près d'une
mesures de couvre-feu que personne ne
sera là pour la faire appliquer c'est
absurde
si pendant six semaines nous tenons ce
couvre feu on est collectivement
responsables justement de d'un
engagement collectif de réduction de ses
contacts à ce moment là nous pensons que
nous pourrons progressivement réouvrir
on sait très bien que on n'a pas les
moyens de faire respecter la loi dans un
certain nombre d'endroits de la
république et que c'est cette loi-là la
loi du couvre-feu qui sera probablement
annoncée ce soir ne sera pas plus
respecté dans les banlieues et qu' on ne
touchera surtout pas aux banlieues parce
qu'il s'agit d'acheter la paix sociale
et de faire de telle sorte que le petit
business puisse continuer à exister
darmanin qui roule des mécaniques on ira
plus restaurant en sortie rapide du
restaurant après 21h qu'on ira plus chez
des amis qu'on n'ira plus faire la fête
parce qu'on sait que c'est là qu'on se
contaminent plus facilement et qu'il
faut réduire et qui fera respecter le
couvre-feu et skhira la police
ce qu'il y aura des militaires je pense
en matinée contre avant oui il y aura
des mesures ad d'abord il y aura des
contrôles et je remercie nos forces de
l'ordre de le faire depuis le début et
il y aura des amendes
[Musique]
le président des états unis en pleine
forme c'est dur c'est dur d'avoir 20 en
c'est dur